here with reaction to that former
Director of National Intelligence John
rackliffe you know we're now over 75
million uh illegal immigrants that Joe
Biden has been aiding and edding into
this country by the end of the year
that'll be 8 million we know that we
have caught some people on the terror
watch list we also know last in the last
week 19 Iranians and 17 syrians were
trying to get into this country how they
got to the Border who paid for their
trip to the Border what their intentions
are I just have to believe none of them
were good um I contend and you tell me
if if you think I'm off base that of
that 8 million unvetted illegal
immigrant you know that Joe Biden's
allowed into this country unvetted I
guarantee there are Terror cells that he
has allowed in is that rational thinking
on my part and how do we possibly weed
them out and find them now that they are
in
here it's unfortun unfortunately uh it
is rational uh rational thought there
Shan I mean nothing
underscores uh the uh lunacy of the
Biden administration's approach um to
Iran than this four weeks ago Joe Biden
sent his top National Security official
uh his adviser Jake Sullivan out to brag
publicly about how great things were in
the Middle East how quiet it was how
they didn't have to spend any time uh in
in the Middle East and now four week
later uh Joe Biden has to send out his
top law enforcement official the FBI
director to warn Americans that um Hamas
and Hezbollah may be bringing the same
atrocities committed against Israelis
and uh Americans over there uh to our
homeland and you know that warning Sean
unfortunately is coming too late um as
Trace Armstrong just pointed out uh or
Galler just pointed out uh this
operation has been planned by Hamas
Hezbollah and Iran for the better part
of a year they would have already sent
their Bad actors here they would have
likely taken advantage of an open border
uh under the Biden Administration and as
you talked about Sean remember there's a
7,000 per increase in suspects from the
terror watch list apprehended in the
Biden Administration versus the Trump
Administration uh and they are coming
from countries like Syria Lebanon Iran
Yemen uh and you know so to to to think
that that they're not already here I
think uh really doesn't make much sense
and the worst part of it Sean is four
months ago you heard Joe Biden's
Homeland Security secretary uh my orcus
under testimony and questioning from Joe
uh from Jim Jordan he was asked those
Terror watch suspects that were
apprehended um have they been released
into the country and his answer under
oath was I don't know we don't know
where they are it just really
underscores uh the idiocy of of uh how
they have approached this problem let's
say that everybody is reporting and
everybody is correct in anticipating
that the ground war in Gaza is going to
begin uh the first thing I would predict
is that Hezbollah and in the north they
will accelerate their attacks into
Israel they'll be firing more missiles I
would expect that the Israelis will be
prepared for that part of it here's
where things become we we enter a Zone
where nobody knows what could happen the
Iranians have themselves have been
threatening to get involved directly now
if they have a two-front war Gaza in the
South Lebanon Hezbollah in the north um
and Iran gets involved I would argue
John Ratcliffe and you would know better
than me that at that point all bets are
off at that point you know Israel will
have to do whatever is necessary to
survive and if pushed against the wall
that could send the entire region into
conflict in my view and it could just be
a head-on battle against Iran and if
that happens I would bet on Israel
because I don't think there's any option
that would be off the table is that a
possibility it's a it's a it's a very
likely uh possibility I mean you're
right Sean I mean actually we don't even
know just with respect to what Hezbollah
can do from the north with 75,000
Precision guided Ians uh whether they
can overwhelm the iron D even without
Iran engaging and you know Sean you've
pointed out some of the things that the
uh the Biden Administration has done
with you know moving the uh Gerald Ford
class and uh Eisenhower strike groups
into the Eastern Mediterranean things in
the last two and a half weeks that are
good for Israel but they've spent 2 and
A2 years helping Iran building Iran
enriching Iran EMB Bolding Iran these
things weren't happening Shan because
they couldn't happen in the Trump admin
Administration Iran was broke and it was
the reversal of the policies of the
Trump Administration that has enriched
Iran and there's a direct and
approximate cause to these events to to
those policies that have been taking
place and you're right all bets are off
no one knows whether uh Israel is is in
a position to be able to defend against
these threats right now yeah scary times
John rockcliffe thank you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else